[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk we're all
things to consider time Peter labelled
ever since the arrival of Boris Johnson
to 10 Downing Street there's a growing
sense of inevitability that Briggs it
will be executed on October 31st with or
without a deal how do we get to this
point what lessons have been learned or
should have been learned
[Music]
Krauss Briggs and I'm joined by
my guess we're no Girard in Paris he is
chief foreign correspondent at La Figaro
in London we have Alastair Donald he is
an associate director at the academy of
ideas and in Edinboro we cross at John
White he is a political commentator and
writer alright gentleman crosstalk rules
in effect that means he can jump in and
Tommy Juan and I always appreciate let
me go to John and Edinboro first here in
my introduction I said there's a growing
sense of inevitability that we will have
brigs it on the thirty-first here am i
off the mark go ahead John yeah I think
with current events it might be that you
may slightly be off the mark because
there's one hell of a battle taking
place here in the UK over on Boris
Johnson and his band of acolytes are
trying to push through Parliament and by
suspending parliament for five weeks and
ramming for my heart breaks it so I
don't think it is inevitable no I think
it may even be more inevitable that
we'll see the end of Boris Johnson's
very short term in government if the
general election does come to pass then
his statement that he made up say in the
comments and I'm saying his plan for
parliamentary procedure to ascertain
whether he will get his way and get
brexit delivered on the 31st of October
it reminded me of Nicolae Ceausescu's
infamous last speech in Bucharest in
1989 the boos and jeers of the
protesters almost succeeded in drowning
Boris Johnson oh so this is a Tory
establishment and complete and utter
crisis unable to rule in the old way and
I think the crisis is no mature to the
point minutes beyond break sir or I mean
and even beyond you know it's never
about this corny old relic of a British
state and about whether you stand on the
ground of socialism and solidarity with
Jeremy Corbyn John MacDonald at all or
on the ground or us but John I mean they
respect of how we feel about it it's
it's still on the agenda here let me go
to Renault in Paris I mean what could
Boris Johnson get from the Europeans
from Brussels that Teressa may couldn't
okay because he's saying he's still open
for a deal even if the window is only a
matter of days that are open go ahead in
Paris no I don't think that he will get
anything because for two reasons number
one the big countries are really fed up
with this
is it Asians that a citation that you
know like sixty years old so they are
really fed up and the second thing it's
too complicated to have like 27
countries agree on a new proposal
because for Foreign Affairs matters you
need the unanimity so technically there
is a techniques of European Union it's
too complicated so Boris Johnson will
not get an anything more he has been
told that by Angela Merkel in Biarritz
and by Emmanuel macron in Paris okay
Alistair the same thing to you I mean
irrespective of how democratic or
undemocratic the Tories gambit is here
it is ramming it through it but Boris
Johnson and his associates will say but
this is what people voted for and he's
just doing the will of the people
irrespective of well it's a bit devious
but then politics and being devious or
synonymous so go ahead Alistair in
London well yeah I think that's that's
correct that he's he's acting on a
democratic mandate and he's trying to
get to a situation where the UK actually
leaves the European Union the problem
just now and the problem that he's got
in terms of concluding any of these
arrangements by the 31st of October is
that steadily and even and rapidly the
rulebook has been torn up in terms of
how politics works there's all sorts of
constitutional issues being arranged
with the Parliament grabbing hold of the
order book and and determining the order
of business there's legal challenges to
what to his capacity to to get us out so
I I think all bets are off just now in
terms of whether you can get us out by
the 31st of October and and you know you
could argue that and indeed I would
argue that those people who
want to delay brexit in fact want to do
much more than that they want to
actually stop that and right from the
outset the mechanisms to stop bricks it
does I have always been posed in a kind
of democratically friendly way
but that mass their real intent which is
really to stop brexit
let's stay with intentions I like that
let's just go back to Edinboro John I
mean Teresa may was the worst person
possible to negotiate Briggs because she
didn't believe in it okay she wasn't she
was a remainder now we have Boris
Johnson which with very kind of a
checkered past he's really kind of
grabbed this thing and and made it his
own and he's gonna fall on his sword on
one way or another when it comes to
Briggs it here but at least he's
embraced it and it seems to me and you
gentlemen in the UK are more familiar
with it than I am
but there's a it seems to me legally
there's not much the out there that can
actually really stop him he's gonna get
this done a deal or not go ahead John
well there are as I also just nation a
couple of cold cases underway right now
court action is being waged to test the
legality of what he's trying to pull off
and so we we don't know that question is
yet to be determined in the courts but
certainly is added a bit of dynamism
above clarity above there about also a
clarity of purpose that was severely
lacking and that contrasts very well
with Julie's I mean with his base but
given what he's trying to do in the last
week or so on cameras or trying to use a
cream to give them permission to suspend
parliament for five weeks so then you
can get an audio break except that's all
changed and i think i take that opinion
is they should move sharply against them
I don't think there's huge appetite for
going back to the mean I certainly
someone who supports it remain in the
election and the referendum peeler
because not because I support you but
because I believe this is a case of cure
being worse than the disease but I think
there's a shift towards a negotiated
break said rather than an audio breaks I
think matter to polls are in which most
people are standing and on this issue at
this current moment in time but of
course there is a huge amount of breaks
that fatigue in the country people want
to see this resolved one way or the
other tired of talking about it and I
think Therese I mean there's a lot of
criticism for the way that she
dilly-dally
along with 13 over these past three
years and these field negotiations with
the EU well I let me go to you in Paris
I'm I'm sick and tired of talking about
Briggs it is well I mean from the
position in Europe I mean this delay
delay three months six months I mean you
need to cut the Gordian knot okay and in
and and and I would suspect since Boris
Johnson and and his supporters are
determined to have a brexit executed
that make it the 31st and be done with
it I mean why keep delaying it okay
I mean uncertainty is the worst thing in
politics go ahead in Paris yes I think
it was a worse thing in politics I mean
the United Kingdom is admired throughout
the world for its old democracy but on
European matters British policy and
British democracy is a total failure
they didn't want to go in the beginning
you know in the conference of missing in
the conference of Rome in 57 they didn't
want to draw in the Common Market they
try to do something a competitor of the
common market which didn't work so when
they realize didn't work they ask twice
to to charge the goal to enter common
market charge the goal refused twice
then they insisted again and again and
finally they entered then they needed a
new referendum and then Thatcher came
and said oh but I don't like the rules I
have to change the rule and so on and so
on
we made euro they didn't want to enter
your oh so it's a wavering and now they
decided by a referendum to leave but
even to leave it's complicated with them
I mean they after three years they they
don't know what they want and the
the House of Commons does not know what
it wants and so I think at least with
Boris Johnson we have square policy I
don't believe that it is the interest of
Britain to leave the European Union but
it is Britain's problem and Britain's
decision but at least Boris Johnson in
my view is doing square and
understandable politics no no me good
Alistair I reflect upon what we just
heard from our guest in Paris
interesting go ahead yeah yeah I think
the the thing to understand here is the
shift that's taken place over the course
of the last three years we have the
referendum in 2016 the political class
were overwhelmingly for remaining within
the European Union and the vote went
against them so it came as a real shock
to them the initial response from
Theresa Mayer's as Ben said was one of
fundamentally damaged limitation in
terms of how they how Britain withdrew
from the European Union she wanted to
moderate the way that we withdrew so
that we could retain as many links as
possible and stay in sync with with our
European partners the problem that she's
had and the problem that Boris faces
just now is that the damage limitation
that he's faced with is the very
existence of the Conservative Party
because the people have taken against
Theresa Mays poor attempt to leave and
have continued to exert pressure on us
to have a break from the European Union
so Boris is forced into the situation of
desperately trying to leave on the 31st
of October because he has he has the
challenge of keeping his own party
together personally I'm not convinced
that he wants a new deal brexit I think
this is a ploy for him to come back with
some sort of moderated version of the
withdrawal agreement which I don't think
will be overly different but which he
can hold up and say well this is what
I've won we're going to leave so III
think you know his his problem is a
tricky one and and the situation we're
in just now is that in a way the middle
ground
the more moderate positions have fallen
apart as remainders have become ever
more confident that they can push
towards a situation or of revoke and
those that want brexit have been forced
by the remain pressure to avoid leaving
to go forever more radical solutions
which has ended up with the desire for a
clean brexit or no bricks that or
however you want to phrase it ok well
it's it's very interesting here and like
what you said you went with the you have
the the moderate views on both sides of
the issue kind of fading away but that's
what makes October 31st they are do or
die in many ways for both sides here
alright gentlemen after a short break
we'll continue our discussion on break
the state with our key welcome back to
crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaBelle's remind
you we're discussing Briggs it
[Music]
let's go back to John in Edinburgh okay
let's work under the assumption that
Briggs it occurs it was Eve if it's on
October 31st or January 31st of next
year it's happened it's that's our
supposition right here there's a lot of
talk here that the you know the UK will
drift into the u.s. orbit because we
have people like Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo just essentially drooling over
the possibility of a new trade agreement
with the UK which of course will have
all those political attachments it would
the deal with foreign policy I mean is
this something that's going to happen
because I think a lot of people on both
sides of this issue say Britain can't
stand alone it's going to have to choose
one side is that really an outcome that
a lot of people that voted in the
referendum are interested in seeing
happen go ahead John no I don't think it
is and I think that's why there's a lot
of opposition both in to Boris Johnson's
attempt to railroad through any audio
breaks it because of the Trump
administration we know the Trump
administration has an involved antipathy
towards multilateral institutions and
multinational trading bloc's and it
prefers to deal on bilateral on a
bilateral basis now the old saying goes
that only the strong can compromise and
only the equals can reach agreement
lebreton does come cold and shoveling
out of the EU without any deal then it
will be vulnerable to any diktats that
Donald Trump imposes on it and we see
from this past behavior he slapped
others not only on America's adversaries
but also Ronis allies the Canada and
France so everyone's rightly worried
about what this would entail for Britain
going forward clearly what is about the
future of the NHS a National Health
Service which is a free health service
at the point of need was introduced by
the post-war Labour government and is a
shining example of social solidarity in
action and people are worried about how
this would survive if Trump gets his
hands on it because you know that these
US health corporations are see the NHS
as a go-to in price and the Boris
Johnson has said give get given
guarantees verbal guarantees that the
NHS will be safe but how can we do that
for sure the conditions of a trade deal
with the US and the UK will have post
breaks a future with
be imposed by the US more than everybody
Yuki and so yes I think people are
greatly concerned about Donald Trump and
intentions towards Britain in the event
of an audio breaks and I think that is
feeding a lot of the opposition even on
the brakes it sounds to the prospects of
an ordeal Gregson let me go back to
Paris here I mean I really appreciate
how you characterize the UK's
relationship with the European Union
before during and I want to talk about
after what kind of relationship what
kind of constructive relationship do you
think the EU will have with the UK post
brexit I mean I'm sure that between
France and Britain the defense
cooperation will go on because it's very
important you have to realize that
Britain and France are the two only
nations in Europe that are ready to
fight that have soldiers ready to get
killed and to kill because an army is
done for that you know and we saw it
everywhere we saw it in in Bosnia for
instance and other armies in Europe
unfortunately I use that for for for
some foreign operations if you like you
can rely only on Britain and France who
are two nuclear powers and who have a
cooperation in all fields of military
including the nuclear field so I think
that Britain will remain a very strong
partner in defence to France as far as
the special relationship with America of
course it will learn go on but you have
to remember something that there's a big
difference between Trump and Boris
Johnson that you saw in Biarritz Boris
Johnson said openly that is pro free
trade when of course Trump is a
protectionist and then also boys will
have to remember that British people is
a proud people and they don't
like when it's too open too clear that
Britain is the poodle of the United
States and when it became to poop too
clear you know and you remember this
summit in some petal smoke when when w
bush called Blair or yo burn asked him
to come like a poodle
to his seat you remember that scene and
because of that the the Labour Party
actually and Britain fired Tony Blair as
the Prime Minister because they cannot
British people is a proud people and
they will not be the poodle of America
and you have seen that in the Gibraltar
crisis in this grace one Iranian ship
that America asked for another you know
British action against the Iranian ship
and Britain you really it's a really
good example let me go to ouch that's an
excellent example but if and as I
mentioned if a new trade deal between
the UK in the United States is dictated
by the United States then you're not
going to have that kind of freedom here
I'm thinking about Iran for example
where France has the European position
and the UK would be open to a lot of
pressure by the United States decide
with it when it's a very unpopular
policy around the world the the Brit the
British would be reduced to having to
have to follow orders and I think again
that's something that's not really been
discussed very much okay I I'm on the
Briggs inside don't get me wrong okay
but there are G o political implications
of it go ahead Alistair well yeah the
huge geopolitical implications I mean I
think no the thing is that if we come
out of the European Union with anything
approaching a clean break where we have
the ability to make our own policies up
and then to enter into negotiations then
we're in a better position than the
decisions been handed down from
organization which were part of but
which as a people as a demos we've never
really had any possibility of
contributing to the making of so there's
lots of scare stories yes but I think we
should take which we should look at the
positive side of this has been able to
interact on something approach as a
starting point on our own terms and
obviously compromises will need to
follow in all of these things but
ultimately if you're talking trade then
we've got companies in the in in Britain
and companies in America and and
throughout the European Union that want
to make products and want to sell them
at a profit so there's a certain logic
in that which will lead to compromises
we shouldn't be afraid of that on the
political side I think we have to we
have some big decisions to be made but
the important thing I think to remember
is that even within the European Union
just now it's not all harmony there's
good from parts of the European Union
that think different things
Italy wants deals with China that
Germany was that's exactly where I want
to go here that's exactly where I want
to go John one of the things that
Brussels is the is so infuriated by
Briggs that is because it sets a
precedent and all isn't happy in the
European home okay and I think all of us
would agree with that but once one gets
out it creates a model - for others to
at least start thinking about it and I
think that's one of the reasons why
Brussels was so rigid with the UK and
they were actually quite fortunate to
have such a weakling as in May so but
the president will be there and it's
something that the the mandarins and
Brussels certainly have to be thinking
about go ahead John
well yeah touching on woman you know
said about being a cuckoo in the nest as
a we're in Europe over the last 40 44
years of his involvement in European
Union as various permutations Brussels
has completely also mishandled this
process because it stuck to a rigid
object line not making any allowance for
the fact that you know skepticism across
Europe has now become a mainstream
political current
a time when it is always on the margin
so we the salvini coalition government
but she just ended in Italy for ban and
hungry the rise of marine lepen gave
builders and whole and then of course
brakes so Brussels has events no sign of
of going to the forum these institutions
reformist practices in democratize and
so it's a case of fiddling while Rome
burns - you're absolutely right you
don't suffer a lot of damage if you care
to leave the sixth largest economy or
fifth largest economy fifty four percent
of all UK imports are from the EU 46 of
all nuclear export to the EU so that
would be a sizeable chunk taken out
especially in Germany car manufacturers
who have a big stake and what happens
with this brexit process so don't lose a
lot of prestige around the world and
it's and its power and influence will be
on the wane we know that people like
Mike Rome want to see the EU politicized
and go move towards being a super state
I think it's further away than ever
largely because of the EU s handling of
this process and the you asked for the
eurozone which will not touch the point
that was one of the best things that
Britain did was not to enter you know so
looker that ended up Nast
that's testament to the foresight of
golden brown he was the labor chancellor
10 years ago and made that decision not
to enter the eurozone but so many
contradictions at the house you know one
does not really know where to begin but
it's the real liberal model that
sustains European Union that isn't
complete okay let's talk about that
model right now let's go back to you in
Paris what what is the biggest lesson
from this whole Briggs if it's
experience from the continent some
perspective go ahead
you know I interviewed the French
secretary last year it was one year ago
and on the lawn of his embassy in Paris
and you know he told me at the end of
the interview to me finally Charles the
goal was right yes they bothered us like
for 60 years finally chose it all was
right I'm not and you know it's a
amazing a foreign secretary telling you
500 jobs are going was right but no I
think that the the European is not in
such a bad state
you like it or not euro is really a good
competitor for dollar it's a very strong
currency it's used by everybody is
getting stronger and stronger people
said five or ten years ago euro will die
I don't see the death of euro you are
you are telling us that Europe is not
United yes there is fights among you not
but not so so such big fights because I
remember that the Italian said function
on the on the on the sanctions to his
Russia that they would they would cool
off and they would they would vote
against the sanctions and you need only
one European country to say we don't
want the sanctions to go on and you have
no more European sanctions against
Russia they the Italians did not do that
so you still have some kind of some kind
of unity and politically practically I
think that the European Union is
actually in a better state then want to
repeat the most important sentence of
this program de Gaulle was right ok many
thanks for my gifts in Paris London and
Edinburgh and thanks to our viewers for
watching us here at RT see you next time
and remember brass knuckles
you
[Music]